[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
einen guten Montagabend Ihnen allen ein
Dach überm Kopf das gehört zu den
absoluten basis-notwendigkeiten für uns
Menschen bezahlbares Wohnen halten die
Parteien durch die Bank für die soziale
Frage des 21 jahrhunderts und deshalb
steht das Gipfeltreffen beim Kanzler in
Berlin heute am Anfang dieser Sendung ob
es auch erfolgreich wird ist damit nicht
gesagt fakt ist Deutschland hat gleich
mehrere Probleme wenn es um bezahlbare
Wohnungen geht die Mieten steigen rasant
und es wird viel weniger neu gebaut als
nötig ist und vom Kanzler versprochen
wurde die Immobilienbranche fordert
massive staatliche Hilfen sie bekommt
einen 14 Punkteplan und einen Schlagwort
aus der pr-schmiede der Bundesregierung
Bündnis bezahlbarer Wohnraum
und was ist dabei geht und was die
Reaktionen sind wir beginnen dazu mit
Bernd Benthin aus Berlin
noch drehen sich die Kräne noch wird
gehämmert gesägt und gestemmt aber wie
hier in Mainz stecken viele
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften im krisenmodus
bauen wird immer teurer Fachkräfte immer
seltener die Branche warnt vor
Stillstand und Wohnungsnot
seit neun Monaten explodieren nun die
Zinsen wir haben nicht mehr 1% Zinslage
wie noch vor einem Jahr sondern
mittlerweile 4%, das bedeutet die
gesamte wohnungsbaubranche in
Deutschland hat eine Vollbremsung
hingelegt steht nun vor dieser
Unfallstelle und niemand weiß wie es
weitergeht der Bundeskanzler wollte auch
baukanzler sein hatte dafür extra ein
neues Ministerium geschaffen eine neue
Ministerin ernannt und im Wahlkampf 2021
ein ehrgeiziges Ziel formuliert wenn ich
sage was wir hinkriegen wollen ist jedes
Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen zu bauen mit
diesen 400.000 hat es noch nie geklappt
bei weitem nicht schon die Hälfte könnte
schwierig werden deshalb heute
wohnungsgipfel im Kanzleramt die
Regierung bringt der Branche ein
Maßnahmenpaket mit
wir präsentieren Ihnen heute 14
Maßnahmen die viel verändern und viel
möglich machen mehr Menschen werden sich
mit unserer neuen Förderung ein Haus ein
bestehendes oder ein neues kaufen können
und darum geht es konkret die
KfW-Förderung von Baukrediten soll
erhöht und leichter zugänglich werden
Haushalte mit bis zu 90.000 Euro
Jahreseinkommen können die Kredite jetzt
bekommen ein verschärfter
Energiestandard für Neubauten wird
gestrichen damit entfallen Kosten und
auch für eine Sanierungspflicht zum
Energiesparen will sich die Regierung
nicht mehr einsetzen von Teilnehmern aus
der Wohn- und Baubranche kommt
vorsichtiges Lob unsere Erfahrung der
Regierungsarbeit in den vergangenen
Monaten oder im vergangenen zwei Jahren
war ja das dann vieles angekündigt und
vieles dann wieder zurück verhandelt
wurde ich denke diesmal waren die
Aussagen so klar dass es wirklich kommt
und viel viel wichtiger noch dass wir
nicht die nächste Schippe Baukosten oben
drauf kriegen die Branche hatte im
Vorfeld die Trendwende herbei gesehen
Experten aber haben Zweifel ob die 14
Punkte den Trend wirklich wenden können
das wird vom Volumen mehr einfach nicht
ausreichen wenn man wirklich Effekte
erzielen wollte wäre eine Möglichkeit
dass der Staat die Sache selber in die
Hand nimmt durch die öffentlichen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften als Bauträger
selber Immobilien errichtet und später
vermietet immerhin so sagen es gibt viel
Teilnehmer gehe etwas voran beim Thema
Bauen der Weg aus der Krise aber sei
noch lang
kaiwaneke vertritt den eigentümerverband
Haus und Grund Interessengemeinschaft
also von privaten Haus wohnungs- und
Grundstückseigentümern genannterweise
guten Abend Herr sie weiß sie haben
heute abgesagt beim Kanzler sie waren
nicht mit dabei hätten sie nicht vor Ort
mehr erreichen können als in der
Schmollecke
und ich glaube nicht dass wir in der
schmoll-ecke waren und werden vermutlich
auch nicht mehr erreichen können sie
haben es ja gesehen der Bundeskanzler
ist vor dem wohnungsgipfel vor die
Presse getreten und hat vorab verkündet
was die Ergebnisse sind das heißt
hinterher hat man eigentlich nur noch
auf einen Kaffee zusammen gesessen
Ergebnisse gab es da gar nicht mehr zu
planen ja sie sagen es gab nur einen
Kaffee aber die die dabei waren also
auch aus der Immobilienwirtschaft die
loben das Paket jetzt als umfangreicher
als gedacht und als Zitaten 9 Realismus
der besonders strenge Energie
sparstandard eh 40 ist vom Tisch
zwangsanierungspläne auf EU-Ebene hat
die Bundesregierung eine Absage erteilt
da war also doch was dabei was doch auch
sie fordern oder
absolut dass der eh 40 Standard jetzt
nicht kommt ist ein sehr gutes Signal
das gleiche gilt auch für die
zwangsanierungspläne das hat Frau
Gallwitz übrigens schon vor Monaten
angekündigt aber Robert Habeck hat es
hinter ihrem Rücken stets weiter
verhandelt insofern müssen wir noch mal
abwarten ob der Kanzler da wirklich
hinter steht aber man muss einen sehen
was da beschlossen wurde bedeutet das
ist nicht zu weiteren Verschärfungen und
nicht zu neuen Kosten kommt aber es
bleibt eigentlich beim Status Quo weil
ihr nur für die Zukunft etwas verhindert
wurde aber nichts rückgängig gemacht
worden ist jetzt sehen sie allerdings
das Problem von Dämmung und von
Energiesparen einfach nur unter dem
Kosten Aspekt andererseits muss man aber
auch sehen ein Drittel des gesamten
deutschen Energieverbrauchs kommt vom
Gebäude Sektor zwei Drittel der
Wohnhäuser in Deutschland stammen aus
der Zeit als es überhaupt gar keine
energiesparregeln gab so kannst du auch
nicht weitergehen
nein es kann so nicht weitergehen und es
soll so nicht weitergehen aber man sieht
es ja gut an diesem Beispiel eher 40
Haus das wäre ja ein sehr sehr niedriger
Energiestandard der dann notwendig ist
wenn man tatsächlich mit fossilen
Brennstoffen heizt jetzt haben wir aber
die Situation dass wir umsteigen auf
erneuerbare Energien und dann ist ein
derart niedriger Standard überhaupt
nicht erforderlich denn man heizt ja mit
erneuerbaren Energien und dann passt
auch ein eh 55 aus dann gucken wir doch
jetzt mal was eigentlich die Probleme
ihrer Branche sind der Kanzler hat
gesagt laut Handelsblatt die Zinsen sein
nicht das Problem Zitat Olaf Scholz vier
Prozent Zinsen Leute im Westen sind 1972
700.000 Wohnungen gebaut worden wisst
ihr wie hoch die Zinsen damals waren
fragte der Kanzler und gab die Antwort
dann gleich selbst 9,5%
ja da blendet der Kanzler allerdings
einiges aus und das ist ja gerade die
fehlende Realität die wir eben hier
vorwerfen der Bau war damals wesentlich
günstiger es gab wesentlich weniger
Bauvorschriften das heißt die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mussten auch
wesentlich geringere Kritiker Kredite
aufnehmen und dann mögen ein paar mehr
Zinsen auch zustimmen gewesen sein aber
heute haben wir derart große finanzielle
Belastungen dass wir sehen dass für
breite Teile der Mittelschicht der
Erwerb von Wohneigentum nicht mehr
möglich ist auch bauen nicht mehr
möglich ist und das Gipfel der letztlich
darin dass wir in den vergangenen Jahren
tatsächlich ein Absinken der
Wohneigentumsquote haben weil immer
weniger Menschen in der Lage sind die
die sich den Traum von den eigenen vier
Wänden zu erfüllen umgekehrt haben die
drei größten privaten
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften in Deutschland
die haben zwar aktuell überwiegend
Verluste aber in all den Vorjahren über
viele Jahre hinweg riesige Gewinne
gemacht immer wieder Milliarden wohnovia
hat so viel Geld dass sie kräftig
eingekauft haben auch im Ausland sollten
die nicht auch eine Krise überstehen
ohne immer gleich nach Geld der
Steuerzahler also von uns allen zu rufen
ja da bin ich durchaus bei ihnen ich
sehe es natürlich aus dem Sicht aus der
Sicht der Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
diesem Land die hat sich der
HauseigentümerInnen und Hauseigentümer
und die haben ja auch von steigenden
Mieten profitiert und profitieren
aktuell immer noch
selbstverständlich wäre vermietet hat in
Teilen auch steigende Mieten allerdings
sind zum Beispiel die Kosten für
Handwerker wesentlich stärker gestiegen
als die Mieten auch die Reallöhne sind
in den meisten Städten auch in Berlin
München und Hamburg stärker gestiegen
als die Mieten und man sieht eben auch
an den relativ geringen
Durchschnittsmieten dass viele private
Vermieter sich überaus Sozialverhalten
und nicht alle haben da ein
polsterwirtschaften können Sie mal ja
auch viele in den letzten Jahren erst
gebaut und gekauft haben aber noch mal
die Frage sollte man wenn man in den
Vorjahren gut verdient hat nicht auch
über eine Durststrecke aus eigenen
Mitteln erstmal hinwegkommen können
natürlich in dieser Phase sind wir ja
auch und wir fordern ja auch nicht dass
wir jetzt hier eine Unterstützung für
private Vermieterinnen und Vermieter
haben wollen sondern wir fordern
lediglich dass die Rahmenbedingungen so
gestaltet werden dass vermieten sich auf
Dauer und langfristig finanziell lohnt
und dass wir nicht das erleben was wir
auf dem deutschen Wohnungsmarkt sehen
das überwiegend Unternehmen Wohnungen
derzeit kaufen die diese handeln wollen
die diese veräußern wollen die
spekulieren wollen es wäre doch wichtig
dass die Menschen in diesem Land die
Immobilien haben und zwar mit der
Möglichkeit sie lukrativ zu vermieten
sagt sagt Kai Warnecke der vom
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund er
Warnecke herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch heute live aus Berlin vielen
Dank danke
unser nächstes Thema eine
Win-Win-Situation so hätten viele die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen Europa
und China in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
gesehen das könne jetzt zu einer lose
Dynamik werden sagt er für den
Außenhandel zuständige EU-Kommissar und
er sagt es nicht irgendwo sondern in
Peking der Besuch aus Brüssel hielt sich
also nicht lange mit Höflichkeiten auf
denn einerseits ist der EU china-handel
wichtiger denn je andererseits immer
stärker politisch aufgeladen und
befrachtet mit Fragen und Befürchtungen
Florian
nehmen wir zwei Elektroautos ein
chinesisches und ein deutsches in den
Werbespots ähnlich angepriesen in der
Leistung vergleichbar nur beim Preis ein
klitzekleiner Unterschied hier der id.3
von Volkswagen für
39.990 Euro dort der MG4 das
vergleichbare chinesische Modell nur
31.990 €
. die chinesischen Autobauer die
verfolgen jetzt eben eine sehr
ambitionierte Wachstumsstrategie die
wollen hier eben schnell Marktanteile in
Europa generieren bieten da eben ihre
Fahrzeuge auch dann eben zu diesen
günstigen Preisen an
chinesische Elektroautos überschwemmen
in Europa es ist ein Horror Szenario
dass die EU-Kommission an die wandmalt
aktuell kommen zwar nur 8% der in Europa
verkauften Elektroautos aus China 2020
aber waren es noch quasi Null und in
zwei Jahren sagt die Behörde könnten es
doppelt so viele sein wie heute weil
China so der Verdacht die Autos mit
hohen Subventionen unfair auf Europas
nackt Brücke auch darüber redet Europas
handeltskommissar heute in Peking
die EU begrüßt Wettbewerb er macht
unsere Unternehmen stärker und
innovativer allerdings muss der
Wettbewerb fair sein und gegen
Unfairness werden wir jetzt
selbstbewusster Vorgehen
zum Beispiel mit einer offiziellen
Untersuchung der chinesischen
e-autosubventionen an deren Ende könnte
man Strafzölle verhängen also nicht wie
aktuell 10% sondern eher wie die USA
fast das Dreifache für manche klingt
eher das wie ein Horrorszenario
die deutsche Industrie und nicht nur die
Autoindustrie ist von Exporten abhängig
über 70% unserer Arbeitsplätze hängen am
Export das heißt Maßnahmen wie Zölle
können zu Gegenmaßnahmen führen es ist
diese Drohung die der Gastgeber heute in
Peking nicht direkt ausspricht aber die
auch in Chinesisch freundlicher Form
mitschwingt
wir haben unsere große Sorge und
Unzufriedenheit über diese
subventionsuntersuchungen zum Ausdruck
gebracht wie hoffen dass die EU Vorsicht
weiten lässt und ihren Markt offenhält
Europa will sich wehren idealerweise
ohne sich ins eigene Fleisch zu
schneiden
so jetzt bei uns du Hannah mit der
weiteren Weltlage ja die Ukraine hat
nach eigenen Angaben den Kommandeur der
russischen Schwarzmeerflotte getötet er
soll bereits am Freitag bei einem
Drohnen Angriff auf das Hauptquartier
der Flotte in Sebastopol ums Leben
gekommen sein insgesamt sein 34
russische Offiziere getötet worden von
russischer Seite gibt es dazu bisher
keine Bestätigung Russland Griff in der
Nacht unterdessen ein weiteres Mal die
Hafenstadt Odessa an Ukraine wurden
dabei unter anderem ein Hotel und der
Hafen getroffen mindestens zwei Menschen
sein ums Leben gekommen
laut dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski sind die ersten us-kampfpanzer
vom Typ Abrams in der Ukraine angekommen
Ende Januar hatten die Vereinigten
Staaten Kiew nach langem Zögern die
Lieferung von insgesamt ein und 30
Abrams Panzern zugesagt zeitgleich
kündigte dann auch Deutschland an
Leopard zwei Panzer bereitzustellen
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius sieht
trotz der Ankündigung Frankreichs seine
Truppen aus Niger abzuziehen aktuell
keinen Handlungsbedarf mit Blick auf die
Bundeswehr vor Ort man habe die
Sicherheit im Auge fügte er hinzu
gestern Abend hatte der französische
Präsident macron den Abzug aller 1500
französischen Soldatinnen und Soldaten
angekündigt Deutschland hat aktuell rund
100 Soldaten in dem westafrikanischen
landstationiert vor knapp zwei Monaten
hatte sich das Militär in Niger an die
Macht geputzt
der baden-württembergische Vize
Regierungschef Strobel hat seinen
Rückzug vom CDU landesvorsatz
angekündigt beim Landesparteitag im
November werde er auf eine erneute
Kandidatur verzichten Strobel ist seit
2011 Landesvorsitzender seine Ämter als
Innenminister und stellvertretender
Regierungschef will er behalten als
möglicher Nachfolger nannte Strobel den
Vorsitzenden der CDU-Fraktion in
baden-württembergischen Landtag Manuel
Hagel
der Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz Betzingen hat mit
Blick auf die Missbrauchsvorwürfe gegen
den Verstorbenen Essener Kardinal
Hengsbach von einer neuen Qualität
gesprochen es würden sich offensichtlich
weitere Betroffene melden was den
Verdacht er Härte sagte Betzingen zum
Auftakt der Herbstvollversammlung der
Bischöfe derweil ist heute früh ein
Denkmal hengsbachs vor dem Essener Dom
abgebaut worden Hengsbach ist als
Kardinal der bisher ranghöchste Kleriker
in Deutschland dem Missbrauchstaten
vorgeworfen werden
Krieg und Krisengebiete Orte an den
Menschen ihrer Heimat verlassen hat
diese Welt wahrlich genug sie hat jetzt
dennoch einen neuen Brennpunkt der schon
länger brodelt aber jetzt so gefährliche
Ausmaße annimmt dass die Folgen weit
über die Region spürbar werden heute
wieder heftige Demonstrationen vor dem
abgesperrten Regierungssitz in der
armenischen Hauptstadt Eriwan gegen den
Regierungschef dort der mit einer
militärischen Niederlage klarkommen muss
und einer Welle von Flüchtlingen er hat
sich in letzter Zeit gen Westen
orientiert traf heute eine Delegation
aus den USA
auf der Karte die wir jetzt sehen wird
klarer was bisher geschah seit
sowjetszeiten streiten die ehemaligen
Sowjetrepubliken Armenien und
Aserbaidschan um die Kaukasus Region
Bergkarabach international gilt sie als
Teil Aserbaidschans es leben dort aber
mehrheitlich Armenier und die hatten
auch die Kontrolle bis letzte Woche als
als er bei Jan Stellungen armenischer
Separatisten Angriff und sie besiegte
und jetzt fliehen sie zu Tausenden aus
Bergkarabach Richtung Mutterland
Richtung Armenien und sagen es war ein
Albtraum
ist auf der armenischen Seite der Grenze
so sieht es aus wenn ein Leben in ein
Auto passen muss vladig und seine
Familie wollten so schnell wie möglich
berkerabach verlassen sie sind zu elft
in einem PKW und froh dass sie es hier
nach Gores Armenien geschafft haben
wir haben nur das hier mitgebracht wir
haben alles zurückgelassen alles ein
dreistöckiges Haus mit Schweinen Hühnern
einfach alles
heute hundertfach seit gestern dürfen
die Menschen bergerbach verlassen lässt
Aserbaidschan sie raus es musste schnell
gehen manche haben nicht mehr dabei als
zwei Plastiktüten
wir haben unser Zuhause verloren den Ort
an dem wir gelebt haben unser
Bergkarabach wir gehören zu Armenien
auch hier ist unsere Heimat aber warum
nur demütigen Sie uns so warum greift
die Welt nicht ein
ihre Trauer mischt sich mit Wut viele
hier fühlen sich vertrieben von
Aserbaidschan dem Erzfeind der
vergangene Woche ihre Heimat angegriffen
hat und jetzt dort die Herrschaft
übernommen hat
am Mittag der Grenzübergang zwischen
Armenien und Aserbaidschan hier sollen
heute mehr als 6000 Flüchtlinge aus
Berker Rabach angekommen sein
auf der anderen Seite der Grenze lange
Staus tausende womöglich 10000 die sich
auf den Weg gemacht haben
im Zentrum von Bergkarabach zeigen nur
noch wenige was dort vor sich geht
Aserbaidschan lässt schon seit Monaten
kaum Lebensmittel Lieferungen in die
abgeriegelte Region sie haben wenig
Benzin wenig zu essen die Müllabfuhr
kommt nicht mehr und als Aserbaidschan
lässt auch jetzt nur wenige Hilfsgüter
durch
zurück in Armenien bei wladik und den
anderen Flüchtlingen sie fürchteten dass
in ihrer Heimat alles noch schlimmer
wird als er bei Jan ihnen jegliche
Rechte rauben würde auch dass die
aserbaidschanische Armee ihnen etwas
antun könnte die Wunden sind nach
mehreren Kriegen tief
es ist einfach unmöglich wir würden
niemals zurechtkommen mit ihnen
wir können uns das überhaupt nicht
vorstellen
bleiben war keine Option so sehen das
viele hier vorerst werden sie nun im
Theater der Stadt gohres versorgt wie es
danach weitergeht das weiß hier wohl
kaum jemand
eine wichtige Rolle spielt Russland bei
alledem langjährige Schutzmacht von
Armenien das aber heute auffällt mit
drohenden Worten in Richtung der
armenischen Regierung Armin Körper ist
unser Korrespondent in Russland die
Menschen wir haben es gerade gesehen sie
fliehen mit dem wenigen was sie am Leib
betragen weil sie Angst haben vor der
Zukunft unter aserbaidschanischer
Herrschaft will Russland den Armenien
jetzt nicht mehr helfen oder kann es das
nicht
ich denke russland hat entschieden den
Armenier nicht zu helfen und
wahrscheinlich erscheinen ihnen einfach
die Party Gegner Armeniens nämlich
Türkei und Aserbaidschan im Moment
nützlicher
Armeniens Regierungschef nicole
passingjan hat gestern eine neue Linie
in der sicherheits- und Außenpolitik
seines Landes vorgegeben er hat die
Allianz mit Russland als nutzlos
bezeichnet und hat gesagt das Land sucht
neue Partner im Westen Russlands aus
Minister Love hat darauf heute prompt
geantwortet er hat paschinian als
unfähig und unzuverlässig bezeichnet als
ein Mann der schon die ganze Zeit mit
dem Westen geflirtet hätte bei all dem
darf man eins nicht falsch verstehen der
Kreml hat heute Armeniens Regierungschef
paschant Finale fallen gelassen das
heißt aber noch lange nicht dass er das
Land Armenien aus der Umarmung frei ist
sehr interessant was du da gerade sagst
und dann könnte man ja durchaus auch ein
paar Parallelen zur Ukraine sehen was
ist denn die langfrist Strategie von
Präsident Putin also ganz konkret ist
denkbar dass er versuchen könnte
Armenien die Unabhängigkeit zu nehmen
also ich bin mir sicher dass das was da
jetzt in Berga Bach passiert ist alles
unter Beteiligung des Kreml passiert ist
die Planung und vor allem das Timing es
ist kein Zufall dass die Ereignisse in
Karbach eskaliert sind genau als der
Ukrainer selenski vor den Vereinten
Nationen in New York die Welt um
militärische Hilfe angerufen hat es kann
sein dass Präsident Putin einfach die
Aufmerksamkeit von der Ukraine ablenken
wollte es kann aber auch sein dass er
den besten warnen wollte seht her es
gibt noch andere Krisenregionen in der
Region und auch die könnten militärische
Hilfe von euch haben wollen das wissen
wir nicht ähm fest steht dass
Armeniens premier brasilian ein
ähnlichen Zickzackkurs gefahren hat wie
ist die politischen Führer der Ukraine
in der Vergangenheit auch getan haben
ein Zickzackkurs zwischen Ost und West
er hat sich sicherheitspolitisch in den
Armen des Kreml gewichst und Zeit
gleichzeitig von dort mit dem Westen
geflirtet dass das ein gefährliches
Spiel ist hat der Kreml einmal mehr
gezeigt wie weit man jetzt mit dieser
Demonstration gehen kann und will das
was heute abend außerhalb der roten
kreml-mauern hinter mir wahrscheinlich
niemand interessante Analyse Armin
herzlichen Dank dafür und dann noch
diese Meldung zum Thema die seit einigen
Minuten bestätigt ist Meldung aus
Bergkarabach danach ist bei einer
Explosion in einem Treibstoffdepot nach
Angaben lokaler Stellen sind mindestens
200 Menschen sollen verletzt worden sein
auch von Toten ist die Rede viele
Menschen sollen dort auf Benzin für ihre
Flucht gewartet haben was die Explosion
auslöste ist im Moment noch unklar
so viel zu diesem wichtigen Thema heute
Abend und jetzt noch mal Johanna
nicht nur der deutsche Wohnungsbau war
heute Thema eines Gipfels auch die
deutsche Luftverkehrsbranche traf sich
heute mit dem Kanzler zentrale Frage
dabei wie kann die Luftfahrt Klima
neutral werden weil rehhalla konnte der
Gipfel dazu heute konkrete Antworten
liefern also konkretes vor allem das
Ziel bis 2045 soll Deutschland
klimaneutral sein Luftfahrt inklusive
und davon abgesehen gab es heute im
Prinzip wenig Konkretes Bundeskanzler
Scholz betont er sieht Deutschland als
Vorreiter beim Ziel in wenigen Jahren
klimaneutral zu fliegen einiges ist
schon in der Pipeline Wasserstoff
betriebene Flugzeuge beispielsweise aber
die gibt's noch nicht den Serie
klimaneutrale Kraftstoffe die sind
jedoch nur in homöopathischer Dosis
verfügbar und sehr teuer die
Bundesregierung hat der Luftfahrt ihre
Unterstützung bei der Forschung zugesagt
und sie will sich für einheitliche
Umweltstandards einsetzen
deutlich wurden heute aber auch die
Befürchtungen innerhalb der Branche wie
sehen die aus also eine Sage der
Luftfahrt sind diese unterschiedlichen
Umweltauflagen in Ländern außerhalb
Europas müssen Airlines beispielsweise
weit weniger das teuren nachhaltigen
Treibstoffs beimischen des spielt
internationalen Fluglinien die Türkisch
Airlines und internationalen Drehkreuzen
in die Hände die dadurch günstigere
Angebote machen können beklagt wurden
auch die hohen Steuern und Gebühren in
Deutschland ja und die Forderung die
Luftverkehr Steuer zu Förderung neuer
Kraftstoffe zu verwenden die stieß auf
taube ohrenscholz verwies lieber auf die
hohen Gewinne die die Lufthansa nach
Corona wieder erwartet vielen Dank
Valerie nach Frankfurt
die EU-Kommission will den Verkauf von
mikroplastik in der Europäischen Union
schrittweise verbieten davon betroffen
sind auch Produkte die mit mikroplastik
versetzt wurden und die Partikel bei der
Verwendung freisetzen so zum Beispiel
Waschmittel Dünger Medikamente oder
Kosmetika einige der Maßnahmen sollen
bereits am 15 Oktober greifen durch das
Verbot will die EU die Verschmutzung der
Umwelt reduzieren
die Spiele der
Fußballnationalmannschaften von Frauen
und Männern werden auch in den kommenden
Jahren live bei ZDF und ARD zu sehen
sein darauf haben sich die beiden Sender
mit UEFA und DFB geeinigt konkret wurden
bei den Männern die Medienrechte für 30
Länderspiele bis 2028 erworben bei den
Frauen sind es alle Länderspiele bis
20027 darunter die nations League und
die vorbereitungs- und
Qualifikationsspiele für WM und em
die deutsche Rodlerin natalie
Geisenberger hat das Ende ihrer
sportlichen ausnahmekarriere bekannt
gegeben mit sechs olympischen
Goldmedaillen ist die 35-Jährige die
erfolgreichste deutsche winterolympia
Teilnehmerin der Geschichte zudem war
die gebürtige Münchnerin 9 mal Welt und
sieben Mal Europa Meisterin der Weltcup
Debüt gab Geisenberger 2007 in Altenberg
und gewann seither 8 mal den
Gesamtweltcup
das ist ein Roman für lange Gespräche so
schön steht es in der Begründung für den
Deutschen Buchpreis die Geschichte einer
Frau die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
scheinbar grundlos ihren kleinen Sohn an
einem Bahnhof in der Provinz zurücklässt
und einfach geht das Buch die
mittagsfrau ist alles andere als
leichter Stoff zum mal eben nebenbei
lesen es wurde ein Bestseller über eine
Million Mal verkauft der Film die
mittagsfrau kommt jetzt bundesweit in
die Kinos mehr als 15 Jahre später und
will das auch schaffen eine Geschichte
erzählen die bleibt Nadia nasser
für die freigeistige helene ist es wie
das Paradies
und jetzt kommt die Haare ab das Berlin
der wilden 20er Jahre sie hat große
Pläne will Medizin studieren Ärztin
werden und sie verliebt sich in den
sensiblen links intellektuellen Karl
aber es ist nicht von Dauer Karl wird
den Widerstand gegen die stärker
werdenden Nationalsozialisten mit dem
Leben bezahlen letzte Momente des Glücks
helene ist zu Anfang als sie sie
kennenlernen eine
offene neugierige junge Frau die ins
Leben sich reinbeißen möchte
und dann aber durch die historischen
Ereignisse wird sie immer mehr
eingesperrt nach der Machtergreifung der
Nazis muss Helene verheimlichen dass sie
sogenannte Halbjüdin ist Schwester
könnten sie mein Puls führen
Parteisoldat Wilhelm verliebt sich
trotzdem in Sieg
und verschafft ihr eine neue Identität
sie heiraten aber die Ehe mit Wilhelm
wird zum brutalen Albtraum
als die Mutter wird wird alles nur noch
schlimmer
sie kann zu dem Kind keine Beziehung
aufbauen
während Wilhelm immer herrischer wird
was bist du auf deine Mutter
kann ich mein Kind von Beginn an lieben
zum Beispiel ja was ist eine Depression
als Mutter was passiert wenn du aufgrund
einer Gewalttat schwanger bist und
dieses Kind im deswegen nicht annehmen
kann das sind ganz spannende Fragen auch
wirklich tabu-brechende fragen ja später
Vater sagt dass du ein blindes Herz hast
aber das glaube ich nicht Wilhelm hat
Helene verlassen sie kümmert sich
alleine um Sohn Peter schwer
traumatisiert wünscht sie sich ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben zurück ohne Kind
dem sie nicht genug Liebe geben kann die
Geschichte ist angelehnt an die
familienbiografie der Romanautorin Julia
Frank ihr Vater wurde als Kind nach
Kriegsende von seiner Mutter
zurückgelassen es gilt als das
skandalösischste überhaupt ein Kind
auszusetzen ein Kind
freizugeben wie es sicherlich seine
Mutter
empfunden hat aber in diesen Zeiten nach
dem Krieg nachkriegen das Mütter glauben
ihre Kinder wachsen überall anders
besser auf als bei Ihnen die mittagsfrau
ist ein großartiger bewegender Film
sensibel erzählt er von der
zerstörerischen Macht von Trauma Gewalt
und Krieg absolut sehenswert
warum bist du weg
ja alles andere als ein beschwingter
Filmtipp aber ein wichtiger und wir
sagen damit danke für Ihr Interesse und
empfehlen Ihnen noch unser heute journal
Update gegen 0:10 Uhr mit Christopher
Wehrmann und von uns allen hier ein
angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in Griechenland
hat sich schon wieder ein Tief
festgesetzt und das bringt hier große
Regen mit sich und es tief nutzt wieder
die Wärme des Mittelmeers und so gibt es
hier Regenmengen von gut 200 Liter auf
den Quadratmeter in den nächsten Tagen
ansonsten herrscht hohe Luftdruck und so
steigen die Temperaturen wieder weiter
an in der Nacht gibt's erstmal Nebel der
kann örtlich schon mal dichter sein
teilweise funkeln die Sterne nach Norden
hin sind die Wolken allerdings auch mal
kompakter bei tiefsten Temperaturen von
zwei bis drei Grad hier also schon
deutlich kälter 11 bis 12 Grad an den
Küsten ja und morgen gibt es erstmal
viel Sonnenschein von der Früh weg
örtlich muss ich den Nebel noch auflösen
am längsten dauert das hier im Südosten
und dann kommt aber auch hier die Sonne
hervor und die Temperaturen steigen auf
25 bis 27 gerade im Osten hier also
schon mal Sommertag ansonsten liegen wir
knapp darunter aber insgesamt ist das
schon relativ warm morgen 20 Grad am
Alpenrand hier ist es am kühlsten die
nächsten Tage die Sonne bleibt uns
Meister erhalten erstmal muss ich den
Nebel auflösen 20 bis 27 Grad am
Mittwoch Donnerstag ähnliche
Temperaturen weiterhin Nebel und Freitag
gibt es hier unter einzelne shower die
durchziehen Temperaturen ähnlich bei 19
bis 27 Grad und damit wünsche ich Ihnen
einen schönen Abend